gonna need your vehicle that one give no
okay it's a gas coming to your gas car
go to the boobs good go to the boobs the
boobs gone it's your natural inclination
it's your phone cuz its natural gas
that's a ramp
oh no shin it's so realistic
[Music]
yeah fast so we're talking running
faster
[Music]
I lose a slight occurs get on that car
you [ __ ] yeah yeah we're hitter who we
steal that car that's fun yeah
oh my god have fun lady we know doing
right over there
wait [ __ ] you got this that's a pole
whatever lady
thank you clever for you lady how did
you break your car can you aim down that
was a warning
see you around these parts again all
right let's get into a high-speed car
chase bye oh you miss you're gonna die
so hard yeah crap I got it thank you
that's really awesome it's so happy by
Road there's got to be like a really
long before Oh way to downtown you're
back great times it looks so good yeah I
go here where I think you're a little
jacked up there from smashing into the
trees yeah these speeds you're
unrealistic it's like cars even on it
yes yeah your cars such as it is
you could try turning real sharply right
now should do slighty boss where's a
boss voice man stop seasons gave you the
finger good you [ __ ] they started the
light anyway reasonable oh wait no how
do I refer to that of a fast runner lady
you know it oh my god okay so you look
both ways as the police are pulling
everyone should leave them a present
right here as they come at you and then
drive away and get on no no whoa
[Applause]
oh my god you were your type of the
parachute no you have a parachute
somewhere oh she's got to equip it
equipment laying in the water the faster
swim Bob I got this I got this
this is gonna be nice
somehow do it again yeah the parachute
so thank you all so much for watching if
you enjoyed this heroes please leave a
like best friends thanks guys we'll see
you in the next video
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba but uh buddy
buddy buddy